[Music]
in the last video we saw symbols of a
few basic electrical components used in
a circuit this is a symbol representing
a battery which is a 1.5 volt cell this
bigger line represents a positive
terminal and the small one represents a
negative terminal this symbol is used
for the buf connected in the circuit it
is just W written upside down in this
way and enclosed in a circle so if we
were to draw the simple circuit using
the symbols then how would we do it just
draw the symbols for the electric cell
and the bub first then using straight
lines for wires join them together this
is the circuit diagram representing the
circuit it was simple to draw wasn't it
you can even show the direction of
electric current in the circuit with
arrow heads so the electric current is
flowing in this direction from the
positive to the negative terminal of the
cell now we have seen in the past
that this is not the only way to light
up above in the circuit for instance if
we interchange the wires connected to
the two terminals of the bulb then the
bulb will still glow this is because the
circuit is still complete and all the
terminals of the system are occupied can
you draw the circuit diagram for this
circuit why don't you give it a try if
you look at this circuit the positive
terminal of the cell which was initially
connected to this terminal of the bulb
is now connected to the other terminal
similarly the negative terminal which
was initially connected to this terminal
is now connected to this one so how will
the circuit diagram of the circuit look
like this is the circuit diagram compare
it with this one you see that we've just
reversed the direction of the battery
hence the electric current in this
circuit is flowing in the opposite
direction so the electric current can
flow in either direction
as long as the circuit is complete the
electricity will slow and the bulb will
glow let us look at this circuit now how
many components does this circuit have
yes three above self and a switch what
is the symbol for switch there are two
symbols for a switch this symbol is used
when the switch is on and this symbol is
used when the switch is off if we were
to draw a circuit diagram for the
circuit then here is what it will look
like note that there will be two circuit
diagrams for this this one is when the
switches off and the electric current is
not flowing through the circuit we see
that no arrow heads are shown here this
circuit diagram is when the switches on
here the circuit is complete and the
current is flowing the arrow heads are
used to show the direction of the
electric current which is always from
the positive to the negative terminal of
the battery now here is a question for
you we know that when the electric
current flows between the two ends of
the filament the filament heats up this
heating up of the filament results in
its glowing and this is how we receive
light from the bulb but if this filament
is broken then will the bulb glow no it
won't this is because if the filament
breaks the circuit will be broken
[Music]